[Música]
Estas son las noticias de France 24 más
de un millón de personas están sin
servicio de electricidad en Estados
Unidos debido a la tormenta invernal que
azota ese país 7000 vuelos han sido
cancelados hasta el momento
recientemente el estado de Nueva York
decretó el estado de emergencia
en Argentina la oposición política
presentará una denuncia penal contra el
presidente Alberto Fernández esto
después de que el mandatario se negara a
acatar un fallo de la Corte Suprema que
lo obliga a restituir fondos para el
gobierno de la ciudad de Buenos Aires
y tres personas murieron y otras tres
resultaron heridas en un tiroteo
ocurrido frente a un centro cultural
kurdo en el centro de París la capital
francesa las autoridades avanzan en la
investigación para poder esclarecer las
causas de este hecho
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora vamos a comenzar en Estados
Unidos allí debido a la tormenta
invernal que afecta buena parte del
territorio del país las autoridades
indicaron que más de un millón de
personas están sin servicio de
Electricidad y más de 7000 vuelos
tuvieron que ser cancelados el estado de
Nueva York declaró recientemente el
estado de emergencia para poder hacer
frente a la situación el informe es de
Rafael Pérez
una tormenta de nieve única en una
generación así calificó el National
Weather Service el fenómeno
meteorológico que potencialmente
afectará a más de 240 millones de la
población estadounidense las imágenes
satelitales muestran grandes masas de
aire sobre la Unión Americana alrededor
de 7000 vuelos fueron cancelados
causando caos de Cara a la celebración
de Nochebuena
nos preocupa mucho que los vuelos se
retrasen o se cancelen afortunadamente
ese no es el caso hasta ahora pero he
estado ansiosa por traer a nuestra
familia aquí a tiempo tratando de ver a
la familia que no hemos visto en muchos
años debido al covid y las carreteras
tampoco son ajenas al problema los
conductores se enfrentan a una
visibilidad casi nula en la víspera al
presidente Joe biden advirtió de la
magnitud de La tempestad en una sesión
informativa
por favor tómense esta tormenta muy en
serio Yo no sé si sus jefes los dejarán
pero si todos tienen planes de viaje
váyanse ahora no es broma
más de uno coma 25 millones de personas
se quedaron sin electricidad igual de
afectada se vio la paquetería por correo
en este sentido la empresa FedEx afirmó
que habría retrasos en las entregas a
nivel nacional para el sábado se espera
mejoras en las condiciones
meteorológicas a medida que la masa de
aire se desplace hacia el este
y también en Estados Unidos El Congreso
de ese país aprobó el presupuesto para
el año fiscal 2023 los fondos para estos
gastos alcanzan los 1,7 billones de
dólares dentro de los cuales están los
45.000 millones destinados para la ayuda
de Ucrania la cámara de representantes
dio su visto bueno a este proyecto de
ley por 225 votos a favor y 201 en
contra esto tiene lugar solamente un día
después de que el senado de mayoría
demócrata también lo hubiera validado
por 68 votos a favor y 29 en contra
evitando así un cierre del Gobierno
Federal Ahora sólo resta que la firma
del presidente quede en el documento
para que entre en vigor
en otros temas de nuestro continente hay
tensión política en Argentina luego de
que la oposición presentara una denuncia
penal contra el presidente Alberto
Fernández La medida tiene lugar después
de que el mandatario se negara a acatar
un fallo de la Corte Suprema que lo
obliga a restituir fondos a la ciudad de
Buenos Aires la capital cuyo gobierno
está dirigido por la oposición Valentina
Torres Sánchez nos cuenta más en su
informe
A solo días de terminar los festejos
mundialistas la política devolvió la
atención y la polarización Argentina la
Corte Suprema de Justicia ordenó al
gobierno nacional que entregue unos 997
millones de dólares adicionales a la
ciudad de Buenos Aires que provienen de
los impuestos recaudados por el fisco se
trata de los llamados coparticipables
que se entregan entre las provincias y
la capital según una tabla de
porcentajes establecida por la ley en
2016 el entonces presidente Mauricio
macri aumentó por decreto la suma que
recibía la ciudad de Buenos Aires del
1,40% al
3,75%. esto justo cuando el gobierno
local quedaba en manos de Horacio
Rodríguez larreta su delfín político
posteriormente en 2020 el actual jefe de
estado Alberto Fernández recortó Los
fondos a la capital del 3,75 al 2,32% y
ahora la corte dictaminó que pasen al
2,95% Fernández aseguró que no acatará
la resolución en un día aciago para el
federalismo por este fallo
tremendo que ha sacado la corte que
genera una enorme desigualdad
entre la ciudad más suculenta del país y
el resto del país la decisión de
Fernández generó un fuerte revuelo entre
la oposición la coalición cívica ya
presentó una demanda penal por
alzamiento desobediencia judicial abuso
de autoridad y violación de los deberes
de funcionario público el presidente
pidió presentó una recusación contra los
jueces de la corte para que no
participen en este proceso
Esto no es contra la ciudad esto es
contra la Constitución nacional
expertos aseguran que la decisión De no
respetar el fallo sí incumple la
Constitución y sectores de la oposición
ya consideran pedir un juicio político
contra Fernández
y no muy lejos de allí en el vecino
chile en la ciudad de Viña del Mar las
altas temperaturas del verano han
provocado incendios que han arrasado con
cerca de siete mil hectáreas unas 200
viviendas y dos personas han perdido la
vida las conflagraciones se mantienen
activas por lo que el gobierno central
decretó el estado de catástrofe en esa
zona costera Andrés triviño nos cuenta
más en su informe
las altas temperaturas en Chile generan
estragos los residentes de viña del mar
en la costa central del país limpian los
daños de un gran incendio mientras las
llamas se mantienen vivas y afectan a
cientos de personas y hogares el
gobierno central decretó el estado de
catástrofe en la zona lo ordenaron subir
a todo andaba buscando una amiga
desaparecía pero no la puedo encontrar
de un caos es un caos esto una ola de
calor que ha azotado a Chile con
temperaturas récord en algunas zonas y
la falta de lluvias ha intensificado los
incendios forestales que ya han quemado
más de 7000 hectáreas menos de una
semana las autoridades calculan que
entre 200 y 500 casas estarían afectadas
por las llamas en Viña del Mar Por lo
cual han desplegado helicópteros y
aviones cisterna además de brigadas
terrestres
Bueno tengo tenemos Pérdida total O sea
la familia yo la tengo dando y mi papá
que está más abajo Así que vine a ver
perdimos todo todo se puede decir
documento perdimos vehículo lo que más
perritas que se me quedaron ancho así
que están por ahí están Están muertas
afectadas a las casas de mi suegra la
casa de mis amigos
bueno se perdió todo
los bomberos han informado que las
condiciones climáticas actuales podrían
contribuir a que el incendio sea
controlado prontamente
vamos ahora hasta Francia tres personas
murieron y otras tres resultaron heridas
en una de las cuales se encuentran
estado grave tras un tiroteo que se
produjo en el centro de París la capital
francesa los hechos ocurrieron justo
enfrente de un centro cultural kurdo
etnia a la que pertenecen las víctimas
las autoridades de la capital están
investigando las causas de este hecho
la calle de John acordonada por la
policía ubicada en el distrito diez de
París alberga un centro comunitario
kurdo fue allí en pleno día donde un
individuo abrió fuego el restaurante y
la peluquería vecinos también kurdos
fueron atacados
vimos gente corriendo y luego entramos
en la peluquería y vimos que había tres
heridos en la peluquería entonces me
pidieron que llamara a los bomberos
el presunto autor de 69 años ya era
conocido por la policía en particular
por un ataque contra inmigrantes así lo
ha confirmado la fiscal de París en el
lugar de los hechos
se trata de personas que estaban
instaladas en tiendas de campaña y la
persona en cuestión atacó estas tiendas
se abrió una investigación a finales de
2021 y la persona en cuestión ha sido
puesta en libertad recientemente
herido sobre todo en la cara el
sospechoso fue trasladado al hospital en
estado de relativa urgencia acto seguido
fue detenido la brigada criminal se hizo
cargo de la investigación fue un acto
racista Las investigaciones tendrán que
decirlo una cosa es cierta Esta es una
de las líneas de la investigación
y la cunda por el ataque la comunidad
kurda de París reaccionó
[Aplausos]
una de las víctimas asesinadas Hoy era
una de las responsables del movimiento
de mujeres kurdas en Francia Por eso hay
un carácter político Por eso hay un
carácter terrorista que nadie intente
hacernos creer que se trata de un simple
atentado orquestado por la extrema
derecha
el presidente Manuel macron reaccionó
ante el hecho calificando los de atroz
así también lo hizo la primera ministra
Elizabeth born quien manifestó pleno
apoyo a las víctimas
hasta que las noticias sigan France 24
[Música]